I play Katie Keene who is a very
optimistic lively energetic human being
who I'd strive to be more like no but
she's um you know the show is all about
the ups and downs of life and follows
this group of friends who are trying to
make their dreams come true and all in
their early 20s and finding love and but
it really is about the strong bond
between these friends it's fun on this
show because Katie's supposed to make
all of her own clothes so all of her
outfits are actually either straight
from the comic or or they're all
one-of-a-kind yeah so it's really fun
for a city that never sleeps
New York has a lot of dreamers I'm just
reading down Fifth Avenue so it's so
funny because when I was doing it we're
you know we're actually on Fifth Avenue
and everyone's just like rushing around
trying to get to work and I'm the only
one smiling like strutting down they're
like what is this girl on and can I be
on it too we filmed in the Lower East
Side at 3:00 a.m. on a Friday and people
were not happy with us yelling telling
us to get that we were like we closed on
one of their clubs so they were really
mad but New York is amazing there's such
an energy here I'm like truly unlike any
place in the world a world Katie Keene
will collide with is the Riverdale
universe it's just the same creators and
we took Josie who played by Ashley she's
on our show and it's flash-forward it a
little bit but tonally it's it's the
complete opposite of Riverdale but has
like all the same great elements that
made that successful as for Lucie
popping up in Riverdale maybe so I mean
yes of course I would love to do that
but I would have to because our shows is
like five years later or something so
there's there's probably gonna be a
crossover because
I think someone could possibly come on
it yes fingers crossed
[Music]